[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i brought another drawings we'll have
another one shout out to la speedweed
oh man well it's clearly an indica
it might be bc
ladies and gentlemen
1000 podcasts
oh my god i am from the future that's
insane
there is no [ __ ] way no it's real
it's real it's real we're the same
person yeah i came from the future how
does a person how does a person even do
that with their body some super
sophisticated genius god robot can you
really do that oh yeah all the time man
that's still insane [ __ ] knots man
there's a lot of people out there that
will critique your technique in lighting
joints
critique everything
this is what's called a blunt
both both of us are barbecued i don't
know what the [ __ ] what do we edible
sound like a joint oh that's right
when i first did your podcast how many
years ago was that i think it was
first time i did it um
i don't remember i think all the people
you've had on the conversations you've
had
with those people right you know how
much of that
would you ever have if it wasn't for
doing your podcast people like that
[ __ ] that crazy [ __ ] that went to
jail what the [ __ ] his name joey diaz
people like that guy i think a big part
of you becoming more comfortable and
more relaxed and becoming who you are
today
is that you
you started becoming successful as a
comedian there might be something to
that there might be something to that
now even that's a funny thing about you
joe do you have tmt in the future yes
have you ever been whacked out of your
mind on psychedelics yep it's a reset
button it changes how you feel about
life you know most people smoke dmt they
do this they smoke it and they just go
wow
you see the stars like this is [ __ ]
nuts man you can see them all jesus
christ you [ __ ] freak out yeah it
changes you it changes the way you think
of things it changes me for sure yeah i
mean i keep going on and on and on what
about dear me
elk's my favorite
[Music]
i know how much you love elk
but peta had a statement that they put
out
all the different elk are dead oh my god
it's a terrible time for humanity it's a
terrible time for us and you're a
vegetarian everyone's [ __ ] only
vegetables i i can't i can't do it
that's when you start doing coke that's
when you start going crazy what
what the [ __ ] man
you're just always doing coke i don't
know what i [ __ ] go into business
with
what are you wait a minute
[Music]
periscope no hey everybody it's perry's
here jesus christ that is a that's
that's a symptom of terrible thinking
whoa
listen this is one of my favorite times
ever it's great i gotta get out of here
if you just watch this whole video you
definitely have a great sense of humor
so please consider subscribing to joke
world i'd love to have you as a
subscriber and follow us on instagram
dms to get these free stickers sent to
your address no questions asked free
joke world stickers anyone who follows
us on instagram thanks for watching
[Music]
you